j'avoue j'aurais pu passer sur le côté
mais je voulais vous laisser profiter de
levrat morgane colas alias eskimos un
enfant devait lille à côté de
châteauroux a fait du graff un moyen
d'expression pour faire passer des
messages son art il le partage avec tous
adultes enfants associations et
dessinent sur les murs de la ville de
châteauroux pour évoquer la paix vous
l'avez compris un artiste qui est donc
la paix mais avec une bombe une bombe de
peinture dans les bacs à gâcher ses
clients
bon normalement et ce qui me tue graf
dans la rue sur des échafaudages et tous
comment tu t'es retrouvé à agrafer sur
sur tableau a changé rencontré quelqu'un
qui m'a offert une expo dans sa galerie
et j'ai dit ok et c'est pas du tout le
même travail que bosser sur mur on joue
sur mais on est sur des sur des très
grosses choses échafaudage échelle lassé
des tout petits trucs et bizarrement je
mets beaucoup plus de temps à faire
quelque chose en 70 cm par la force on
va quand même faire une fresque de 7
mètres par 3
j'aime ce qui est décalé de grâce et
décalé c'est un peu en marge de la
société et graff et des danseuses sur
une portière s'est décalé au sein du
travail donc c'est totalement ce que
j'écris aussi des bouteilles 1 que sur
lesquels tu grattes comme ça moi je
m'installe sur plein de support encore
une fois c'est une façon quitter les
tableaux mais je vois que tu m'as fait
honneur je me destinais qu'on le bandeau
et vert mais
on dit presque un villa vous pouvez même
voir christophe notre ingé son
alors qu'il n'avait jamais rencontré un
don esquimaux et dans le futur quand il
anticipé rencontre ces jeux c'est génial
et puis le profit que tu vois tout en
bas là a été réalisé à peu près en 4 5 m
2 au 12 mètres de large c'est un gros
bazar si tu vas aller le voir alors je
te suis c'est ce qu'ils m'ont
en fait le nombre sur l'autoroute avant
et j'ai trouvé le grand mur
d'un graphe une telle dimension ça prend
combien de temps à réaliser celui-ci
s'était dans le cadre du loisir donc ça
m'a pris trois demi journées à pied dans
le cadre d'une commande j'ai multiplié
le temps par jeu ou par trois histoire
que la finition soit nickel ouais et que
ce soit beau de freecom de long parce
que toi tu graf j'ai peur pour le
plaisir pour t'exprimer mais aussi pour
partager avec les gens d assaut et des
enfants en particulier
ouais c'est ça ouais j'essaye de penser
à ce que les jeunes vont voir dans la
pratique et leur inspirer une notion de
respect
artistique plus qu'une notion de
vandalisme et de ont détruit tous qu est
assez commun dans le graffiti mais là on
est en 2022 il faut peut-être face à
autre chose et c'est plutôt bien
accueilli par tout le monde chez moi
ici on est à beaulieu c'est une quartier
le plus peuplé de toute l'inde j'ai eu
une commande de la part de la ville
réalisé une fresque murale sur le mur
d'une école maternelle d'accord et
j'adore ce concept magnifique avec la
colombie to b j'ai justement tatamis les
enfants à contribution pour réaliser
cette oeuvre ouais ouais c'est ça l'idée
émane de et le but ça a été tout compilé
pour en faire une oeuvre tu vois ça
amusant parce que quand je sortais de
mon école à cet âge là il y avait une
fresque murale d'accord et là je suis
trop content parce que du coup cette
fois ci c'est moi qui ai posé une
fresque murale avec mon message à moi
enfin de notre message est sur un petit
garçon qui veut dire ouais bon vin on
quand je te petit avait une fresque
ouais donc le boucler ouais ça serait
cool ça fait six ans maintenant que tu
graf quelle est ta plus belle oeuvre se
battre je te l'a montré les la hausse
incroyable
pro 3d
c'est vivant et tout cas ouais ok c'est
du génie ça c'est comment s'appelle
cette oeuvre s'appelle diane pas médiane
et franchement on diane le plus beau
grave que j'ai jamais vu dans mon
existence bombe un coup de gilles simon
je vais chez les